it turns out that jody turner smith and
joshua jackson
didn't want to wait for their lives to
be over if anyone wants to know i'm
singing the theme song to dawson's creek
uh before popping the question so the
dawson's creek star shared with jimmy
kimmel on the tonight show
that is actually jody his lady who
proposed to him
your wife is uh jody turner smith uh a
very talented actor
so please give her my best um i saw this
online that made me laugh this is your
wife
uh rocking a a pacey t-shirt oh yeah no
this
this popped up like eight or nine months
into our relationship i'm not exactly
sure who the amazon seller is that keeps
the pacey shirts on hand but she is
their core customer uh did you guys
always know that you were
destined knew that you were gonna get
married uh i knew the moment she asked
me
she asked she asked me yeah on new
year's eve we were in nicaragua
it was very beautiful incredibly
romantic we're walking down the beach
and she asked me to marry her
she just said we what there was
like a preamble there was a lead-up to
it did you know that it was gonna happen
i did not know but she was quite adamant
and she was right
this is the best choice i ever made ah
that's what i'm talking about
okay so the question is and then i'm
going to geek out about how much i love
joshua jackson in a second
would you be cool proposing to your
partner
hell to the nah okay i don't even text a
man first
i won't even text rian first
i am not that girl i don't even wanna i
won't even if i wanna hang out with you
on the weekend i won't even ask you
what you're doing this weekend i will
wait for you to come to me because
i come from this old school thinking and
it's probably old school
but i come from this thinking of like
you know men
generally on a primal way they go after
the things that they
want and they show you that they want it
you know and i don't ever want to get in
the way like i want to be the moving
goal post
you know just moving goal post come
after me
okay you know what i'll tell you
jody she's a cool chick she's
different she's just like i i love
it i love her and good for her she's
married so she's doing something right
i'm gonna just keep doing this
away from the parents no you know it's
really funny they've been even though
they're private they've been pretty open
like so
jody his wife uh basically let everyone
know that they had a one-night stand
and then it worked which is awesome
because that doesn't
always happen um they didn't do anything
that was you know
traditional i guess is the word um but
they seem so fun
she wears dawson's creek shirts with his
face on it like
it's hilarious so look i'm a huge uh
joshua jackson fan
i love him on dawson's creek i just
interviewed him for dr death
he you know when you interview someone
who's like someone you
loved when you were younger and you're
like please be awesome because if you're
not
in real life that will crush my soul he
was even better
he he literally is like pacing in real
life so if anyone loves dawson's creek
as much as me he's like the real deal
he's so awesome so look
i'm just so happy that he is happy his
baby jody seems like such a cool chick
and she proposes that's awesome i don't
know
if i would propose yeah so like you but
it was very instilled in me by my mom
it's like
don't go after guys or you know your
partner's name
um so i i would probably wait
but um i will say that i have had people
in my life who have been proposed to who
were
not ready did not think that was coming
and and that has also surprised him and
had some negative effects so
you know yeah at least she knew she was
ready
she did she knew what to do hey good for
her because she got a ring a baby hey
sis go ahead yeah
yeah so addy's saying i totally do it i
figure if you think the relationship is
at that point take your shot
uh aj's saying yeah it's a bit
old-school keisha
well i guess we're both old school yes
all right i have been engaged i haven't
engaged though okay
yeah so i do know what to do okay
wait wait further than